on en parle comme la grande révolution
de demain l'intelligence artificielle
qui fait déjà partie de notre quotidien
au point tel qu'elle transforme des
grandes sphères dans notre vie mais
c'est le le sujet de laisser écrit par
steven guilbeault en librairie à partir
de ce mardi
ça s'intitule le bon la brute et le
truand et est inspiré du célèbre film
qui porte le même nom avec moi steven
guilbeault est ce matin en studio
bonjour monsieur guilbeault bonjour
alors pourquoi une écologiste est comme
vous s'intéresse à l'exercice ben en
fait je suis arrivé à l'intelligence
artificielle par l'écologie c'est à dire
que en travaillant beaucoup sur
l'électrification des véhicules depuis
plusieurs années notamment lorsque
j'étais chez équiterre quand on
s'intéresse à l'électrification des
transports on lit on parle avec des gens
là dessus mais on commence on apprend
aussi rapidement qu on est déjà rendu à
la prochaine étape de l'électrification
soit l'automatisation des transports et
qui dit automatisation des transports d
intelligence artificielle
on sent un peu comme ça que j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à ce sujet là et
l'idée du livre est venu au fil de ses
lectures de ses discussions pour montrer
qu'il y avait qui va y avoir de très
bons aspects et des aspects très
positifs au développement il à
l'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle
alors c'est toute la catégorie catégorie
du bon la brute baisse est évidemment
les aspects beaucoup plus négatif de
l'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle et le truand c'est quelque
part entre les deux on n'est pas sûr est
ce que ça va être bon est-ce que ça va
être mauvais lancer ça dans votre essai
vous divisez l'intelligence artificielle
en trois axes principaux dans le bon
vous l'avez mentionné la santé
l'électrification des transports dans
les mauvais aspects ce qui vous inquiète
le plus en tant qu'écologiste ce sont
les qu'elle en fait je voudrais que les
aspects qui m'inquiète le plus c'est pas
en tant qu'écologiste parce que les
recherches que j'ai fait les gens qui
avaient qg j'ai discuté pour faire ce
livre là m'amène à conclure que d'un
point de vue environnemental les effets
vont être largement positif pour
uniquement positif mais largement les
effets des changements climatiques ça
l'utilisation accrue de l'intelligence
artificielle va beaucoup beaucoup nous
aider notamment ni
du transport de l'énergie on commence à
utiliser on va utiliser de plus en plus
l'intelligence artificielle pour gérer
nos réseaux électriques pour qu'il ya
moins de pertes pour qu'on utilise
l'énergie à meilleur escient dans le
système des transports non seulement
s'en va vers un système de transport
électrifié mais de plus en plus
automatisés
ça va être super intéressant parce que
bon évidemment ces voitures le vent est
électrique donc beaucoup moins de
pollution
beaucoup moins d'accidents des jeunes il
ya des voitures qu'on peut acheter
commercialement qui ont certaines
fonctions d'automatisation différents
niveaux et et gran sasso certaines
entreprises ont noté une baisse du
nombre d'accidents d'à peu près 45 % les
experts estiment que si on avait un
système entièrement automatisé de
transport la réduction du nombre
d'accidents serait d'à peu près 90 voire
95 pour ça et pour faire un lien avec
l'automobiliste qui vous inquiète
particulièrement
c'est ce que vous surnommé le pétrole du
21e siècle donc les données oui cette
expression là et pas de moi mais elle
est de plus en plus utilisé pour
plusieurs les données donc ce qu'on
laisse traîner quand on va sur internet
nos informations personnelles
nos amis nos habitudes de consommation
évidemment nos informations économiques
personnels
tous ont une grande valeur et va être la
pierre angulaire du développement
économique du 21ème siècle
les données vont être ce que le pétrole
a été au xxème siècle pour plusieurs est
présentement il ya très très peu
d'encadrement réglementaire législatif
sur l'utilisation de ces données là on
commence à voir
on commence à voir sont un peu l'union
européenne a adopté une réglementation
très intéressante mais en amérique du
nord et dans plusieurs autres pays
il ya très peu de chose présentement
vous êtes très occupé ces jours ci parce
qu'avec un jour à peine vous avez publié
finalement le rapport final de vos
recherches
en tant que maman fait au président du
comité consultatif du gouvernement
trudeau de change beaucoup
le rapport final c'est quoi le maire
je l'avais que vous lancez une istres le
mandat que nous avions reçues la
coprésidente moa vous emmenez moi était
de proposer de nouvelles mesures pour la
lutte aux changements climatiques au
canada donc des mesures qui permettrait
de bonifier le plan de lutte aux
changements climatiques
on a fait effectivement la semaine on a
déposé la semaine dernière un rapport
final nous avions également déposé un
rapport provisoire au mois de février
juste avant le budget dans lequel ont
proposé la mise en place d'un certain
nombre de mesures comme un incitatif
pour l'achat de véhicules électriques au
niveau canadien ce que le fédéral a fait
des investissements importants pour la
rénovation écoénergétique des bâtiments
il ya un point trois milliards de
dollars qui ont été annoncées dans le
dernier budget fédéral essentiellement
confiée à la fédération canadienne des
municipalités pour qu'elles puissent
accompagner des municipalités partout au
pays pour rendre les bâtiments existants
plus efficace d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue énergétique alors on est
très heureux de voir de constater que
plusieurs des mesures qu'on a proposé
sont déjà mis en place ou sont en train
de l'être dans le rapport final
enfin on propose plusieurs autres
mesures beaucoup dans le domaine du
bâtiment parce qu'on avait travaillées
plus sur les transports pour leur accord
provisoire des mesures par exemple
l'amortissement accéléré pour des
rénovations écoénergétiques dans des
bâtiments
ça se fait dans plusieurs états
américains donc vous investissez pour
améliorer l' enveloppe énergétique pour
améliorer les systèmes donc la
consommation d'énergie de votre bâtiment
ont fait un no 10 à 20 près et si vous
atteignez un certain niveau d'efficacité
25 % d'amélioration d'efficacité
énergétique ou 30% et l'on vous
permettent d'amortir sur une année
toutes les dépenses qui ont été liés à
sousse qui est un incitatif financier
intéressant pour des propriétaires de
bâtiments
donc ça fait partie des recommandations
vous avez fait au premier ministre
justin trudeau ou es ce que vous avez
aimé votre travail auprès de la
politique est ce que vous avez envie de
faire le saut mais nain en politique
active mais c'était très intéressant ce
travail là parce que pour la première
fois bon je fais le travail que je fais
depuis longtemps mais toujours un peu à
l'extérieur du gouvernement l'a pour ce
mandat là j'étais je te bon je
travaillais pas à temps plein pour le
gouvernement mais mais j'étais membre en
quelque sorte de l'administration
publique
ça a été intéressant de voir comment on
peut faire avancer les choses quels sont
les défis les enjeux j'ai une décision à
prendre l'eau au cours des prochaines
semaines savoir ce que je vais faire
pour pour la suite des choses elle n'est
pas prise encore cette question leur est
souvent là parce qu'elle est les
exemples fédéral qui s'en viennent aux
municipales aussi l'un peut-être pour
aller remplacer le cuir on essaie ça
vous dirait tout ça c'est que je vous
avouerai bien humblement que j'ai pas
beaucoup penser aux ayants ayant
beaucoup beaucoup penser au cours des
derniers mois au fédéral je peux
beaucoup penser aux municipales mais
effectivement il ya des élections
fédérales qui s'en viennent
je vais devoir décider si quelques
semaines ce que je vais encore quelques
semaines de travail pour chose pour
faire la promotion du livre et oui c'est
ça le lancement d' il est donc ce mardi
aux éditions druide le bon la brute et
il est très bien mais si vous poussez
mme guilbeault merci à bientôt